so it's different for everyone
but for me it's just kind of rough it
can make users physically repulsed by
food
proponents say it's a miracle diet drug
critics call it an eating disorder in an
injection I'm down to 172 pounds like it
was magic type 2 diabetes
until recently as mpic was used solely
to treat diabetes but once it was shown
to cause dramatic weight loss the
internet and drug companies came alive
and you may lose weight adults lost up
to 14 pounds even with a list of
potential side effects that includes
pancreatitis gallstones and maybe
increased risk of thyroid cancer asempic
use is booming you can see any needle is
very
fine and small and just kind of dial
that up and then you just kind of put it
in and inject
simple as that simple Dr guyana's Clinic
offers Botox skin tightening and vaginal
rejuvenation but lately he's inundated
with requests for a zenpick people call
me all the time from different countries
and states so it can be prescribed like
no we have to see you in the office yeah
the biggest complaint I get is patients
go into their
you know our favorite restaurant and
they're like I had a two bites of steak
I'm like I can't eat it I tried another
one I almost want to throw up great
don't eat it
Elon Musk says his felt appearance is
owing to the controversial injections
speculation is that its use in Hollywood
is Rife there's definitely talk of
celebrities it's definitely out there
I've heard they said Kim Kardashian did
it for the met I don't know if that's
true then it started coming off there
Samantha Glasser has been taking as mpix
since April I was probably 205 but I do
know in May I was like at 189. when I go
off of it I will still maintain the same
lifestyle that I've created for myself
it's been a learning process with it a
nutritionist Kim is a convert to do you
worry that it's quite extreme sure at
first I did because
it was um you hear that someone's sick
and they're you know willingly taking a
medication that's going to cause them to
be sick but then you realize it's all
relative how sick are you
it's a mild nausea and you take the pan
off another controversial side effect is
a zenpix soaring popularity has resulted
in a shortage in the drug for diabetes
patients in the UK it's only approved
for type 2 diabetes patients not weight
loss I certainly have patients that have
struggled to access the medication and
either have had to miss doses which puts
them at risk for sort of weight gain and
uh and higher blood glucose levels and
and at a minimum they're often having to
go from Pharmacy to Pharmacy to Pharmacy
to be able to find where they can get it
in the land of fast food where more than
a third of adults are obese a quick fix
for weight loss is the Holy Grail no
matter what the cost Martha Kellner Sky
News Los Angeles